[Music]  entire safety video is produced by the  Nebraska LaVista Police Department using  real police officers and their own  computers how can I help you my cat is  stuck in the street and she won't come  down hmm I think I've got it Thank You  officer you're welcome what are you guys  coming  [Music]  I'm officer Matt flap in Nebraska's  LaVista Police Department and I'm  officer Trask Rich's did you know the  Taser also has many non-combat  applications that could improve and  enrich your everyday life such as  staying awake while driving  [Music]  home perm pranks providing an intimate  moment between you and a recently  deceased loved one sorry for your loss  [Music]  [Music]  the sea is my Dominion at least two more  things to stand in as your days are good  it's the only partner police officer  needs both on and off duty wink  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you